said you thought the democrats had
control of the polls or had influence in
the polls as well what evidence have you
seen of that yeah i think without a
doubt um there's just no justification
with for some of the misses that we've
seen uh you know there there are a lot
of problems and we call them artifacts
you know depending on your methodology
that you create artifacts within polling
that uh will result in problems you know
distortions in your results and you'll
be wrong but you can't be that wrong
that you're biden plus 17 in wisconsin
well yes that's not an accident how did
this happen at the polls were just so
blatantly wrong yeah well in 16 i'm
getting to be i'm more of a cynic now
and i'm basically a full-blown cynic but
after 16 i really was naively thinking
that if we just kept performing better
than everybody else they'll realize that
look i see your problems just pay
attention and and uh and adjust your
methodologies but they never did and in
18 everybody wanted to whitewash how bad
the senate polls were especially uh
looking at just the national generic
ballot vote and house vote for for the
house of representatives but the
presidency was coming and in 2020
obviously every presidential election
those are state-level polls you know
there's the national poll almost doesn't
even matter so if you had a problem with
the state polls in the senate races in
18
why could you legitimately ignore that
moving into a presidential election
unless you're in you're intentionally
doing that was it who was it nate silver
he who was like i did a good job you're
wrong and it's like his polls were
miserable he's he is a glorified pole
reader he is not really a modeler he's a
glorified pole reader who has a lot of
money for i.t on his site and dev on his
site and he's got some really cool tools
that you can look at and get almost
glamoured into thinking there's
something magical or special happening
there there's not there's not he he
reads polls like any news consumer can
read a poll and i constantly see him all
the time he's a polling guru the media
will call him he's never conducted a
poll in his life and i've told him
actually prove me wrong come to my
office i'll give you the reins you can
sit in front of the software i'll even
give you my sign in you show me how you
do this better but he would never do an
exercise like that he wouldn't know the
first thing to do so are the polls wrong
right now
uh yeah i mean there are some that are
doing the best job they can i have no
problem saying that i mean this the guys
at susquehanna they try their best jim
lee over there uh robert kahelia
trafalgar you know there are a lot of
people out there that are really trying
to just adjust to this changing world
the rest of them i got to tell you i
mean these repeat offenders tim
they know they know they had a problem
the years before the morning consults
the reuters uh
the the yougov uh anyone who buys you
gov data they know they have these
problems so there is no legitimate
reason for them not to put a pause on
their polling after an election to
figure out i gotta retool here i gotta
figure out what i'm doing wrong nope
they go right into it yeah you were
saying that in the modern age that the
way people collect polling data has
changed like they used to do it all by
landline for instance and now people
don't have landlines so they got a text
but some people don't answer texts so
they got to email like
what and but but people they they
realize that they're still just calling
landlines and that they're just not
changing course is that the problem yeah
and and this idea that the live caller
which is you know you the pollster hires
a call center most of them don't have
call centers themselves in-house so they
can't you know basically sub-contract
them out to a vendor and uh there's a
lot of money in it so that's another
major problem obviously the cost of a
poll a live caller poll can be anywhere
and they hate it when i do this on shows
just tell people how much it costs but a
live caller poll could be around 20
grand you know because each interview is
going to be about four or five bucks to
complete
and
somebody who's doing peer-to-peer text
messaging online panels they could do it
a lot cheaper
so part of this is that there's a boys
club and if you evolve or you force the
industry to evolve
they're losing money
interesting what's a peer-to-peer method
oh that dumpster actually i should have
i should have explained that look you
used to be able to just get bombarded
with taxes and most of the time those
were automated software's that just hit
you up like i would upload a csv file to
the software and your name was on it
your name was on it but nobody's really
on the other end 10 dlc is a new
regulation for pollsters and other
people who want to text but it hits
pollsters hard you have got to have a
live agent on the other end of that so
maybe it could be tim who sends out 10
000 himself invites but if somebody's
there to respond you have to be able to
reply or you have it has to be a live
person on the other end is it that they
have to be able to reply or they have to
reply not have to be able the truth is
most of them don't uh which is kind of
defeats the purpose and is a problem
because this is 10 dlc is the last
attempt by the private sector to get
spam to your phone under control if they
don't the government's going to step in
and uh the cost will go up even more and
the regulations will get even more
strict
but you have to register if you do if
your upholstery does peer-to-peer you
have to register you have to do what
what is basically a verification of your
company and you are legitimate and
you're not just spam and then there's
like little tricks you have to do make
three or four you know so
how many how many times how many past
elections have we seen major errors from
the pollsters 2016 20 18 20 20. yeah
it's actually worse than that 2016 just
showed it because it was a presidential
miss and that doesn't normally happen
years before gallup was the gold
standard gallup was generally right
until they messed up in 2012 but 2016
was a real big miss and presidential
polls typically are more accurate than
other polls uh so it got everybody's
attention but truth be told the exit
polls have bombed for many years two
thousand and they called florida for al
gore uh
right way too early because they
believed the exit poll data they did it
again in o4
for all of the people who pined about
january 6
democrats challenged the electors in the
senate in in 2004 based on this
ridiculous analysis that according to
the exit polls there is no way that john
kerry could lose the state of ohio well
exit polls are flawed yet they tried to
hold up electors over it so we saw uh in
2020
some safe democrat districts turned
republican yeah now you got the new york
times saying far right latinas with myra
flores that's ridiculous
what do you think's gonna happen in uh
uh in november all right with myra
flores are saying it's a fluke she won a
special election because a bunch of
republicans came out but she won't win
again do you think it's gonna be
better than is it going to be a red wave
red tsunami or is it going to be
maybe just get by a little bit yeah in
myra's case just to say uh that was a
low turnout older people who have more
uh ancestral connection to their voter
behavior so if your family is democratic
it's always harder for the older people
in the family to change that pattern of
behavior so in the november election
more younger people will be out so
they'll have less of a loyalty a strict
loyalty to to the partisan voting index
it's called and my that will help myra
so people are wrong with that really
yeah it will actually help her because
there'll be younger people who aren't so
loyal don't have this history voting
democrat um there'll be more of the the
shift that we see we've been seeing uh
you know the short answer with
republicans i think it's a foregone
conclusion they're going to take the
house but they're blowing the
opportunity to break their cap in the
house majority and i mean i can get into
that sounds like it's on purpose to be
honest me too i absolutely believe that
but i will say we'll talk about that but
i just want to add one point you know
considering that um
mary here is the typical gen z i think i
think it's going to be a red wave across
the board because every gen zero
believes the same thing as mary just
proves it yeah that's how polls will
she's of course gen z is all catholic
conservatives you know i mean and female
yep pretty representative yes um i want
to know do do you think that uh
inaccurate polling manipulates uh public
opinion
it does and is that really the intention
behind it behind not improving and
fundraising
and fundraising so if you're biden and
polls are starting to show a tightening
election
but then abc news for langer research
conducting it for abc news comes out
with that 17-point lead in wisconsin
well you know wisconsin's a must-win
state for donald trump so you stop
giving to donald trump oh he's going to
lose my guy's going to lose i'm not
gonna give him 50 bucks this month um
and i i didn't believe that before but i
do now because it's more than just
they're not listening they're smearing
they're coming after me they're coming
after robert they're coming after jim um
it's not just all right these guys have
a different philosophy let's see who
performs better and at the end of the
day let your track record win no they
come at you they smear you and they
attack you so
that's not professional and it's not the
way this industry works in any other
arena
if you're if you polling is used for a
lot of different things we just care
about political polling more because
people people are you know in elections
uh but it's it maybe it's potential for
branding right it's the only area of
public polling where this happens well
i guess maybe it's not an error maybe
they're not screwing up maybe they're
intentionally lying in the polls to try
and trick people into voting a different
direction yeah i think that's definitely
happening on at least on some level but
there there are some people that have
just you know they've tried to retool to
him but they just keep screwing up
because that's
incompetence
it's a rock it you know it's tough it's
not easy to pull it's a hard job it is
so i try to give them leeway but at this
point
another thing i want to know um why are
presidential polls traditionally more
accurate
you know i
just higher stakes there's different
philosophies with that yeah i think
honestly you have people who are a
little bit more willing to tell you how
they're going to vote but also
this may change in the future because
the country used to be demographically
more similar like if you were in uh ohio
it didn't look all that different from
another rust belt state like illinois
for instance but now it does demograph
demographics are changing quite a bit so
i think that might change but it
most people would probably tell you that
it's easier to go after larger groups
larger populations than it is to go
after populations that are a little bit
more you know it's it's more granular i
think uh error rates are bigger with
smaller groups people moved all over
because of covid we saw massive exodus
from california we saw people flocking
to florida and texas so this is going to
have a huge impact that pollsters
probably aren't prepared for maybe you
are
we ask about
you know we this is something i don't
know
my laura sometimes i say something on
you know live and she'll she'll be like
don't tell people that that's a secret
but we ask about generation were you
born in the state
are you second generation are you third
generation uh to try to catch that and
we also ask
more than just race we ask ethnicity if
you tell us you're white okay what would
you consider yourself german italian and
you could pick other maybe you're malty
that's fine but most which one do you
most identify with if you're hispanic
are you puerto rican or cuban
are you mexican guatemalan i mean what
what is it asian same thing chinese
filipino japanese we're the only ones
who do this and some of that tim is to
try to catch stuff like that you know
there's there is a more you ask if you
can get some of this information it
should throw up red flags that maybe
you're missing something or there's
there's shift coming beneath your feet
that you got to try to catch thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you